hallo wir wollen etwas geht auch
herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren
block aus madeira
heute wird was ganz besonderes passieren
und zwar werde ich tätowiert ich werde
nicht nur tätowiert doch eigentlich wäre
ich nur tätowiert aber das besondere an
der sache ist dass ich von jan von
gewitter im kopf tätowiert werde ich
töte dich wie so mache ich das ich bin
sehr gespannt und wir werden schauen was
passiert wir befinden uns hier bei der
villa von jan und cengiz und den ganzen
anderen wird durch das ams ist feinster
völlig plem sie also heute werden glaube
ich irgendwie 5678 tattoos gestochen so
als allererstes starte die haben mit
seinem tool wodurch diese ganze aktion
hier natürlich ausgelöst wurde ist
gefallen und wir haben sie an
die beiden hatten die idee hatten auch
die idee für das motiv was wir das soll
den apfel
wo soll der apfel denn hinkommen ich
glaube da kommt neben die ganzen tricks
die ich schon habe ich hier nicht töte
dich schickt die beiden minister habe
die ich hier oben verlinkt habe das ist
einen teil 1 und 2 wo ich meine beine
tätowiert hat obwohl man keine sorge mir
geht's so langsam zum bisschen anders
ich werde hier gebracht ich hoffe mich
aber wer vielleicht drin
das wäre schön hast du eigentlich lag
gesoffen hat
die gerade so warum mache ich das risiko
bestimmter dann geht es wird noch ein
bisschen arbeit ja auch okay jetzt kann
es mit dem stift malen also es ist jetzt
der kompliziertesten finde ich weil ich
nicht malen kann
carina es braucht neue handbuch die
ganze zeit dass man sich einmal an der
macht ist sie an und läuft auch durch
sein aber vielleicht könnten wir uns auf
die innere oder die äußere festlegen
weil das ist ja ich wollte sagen mir ist
und deshalb fest
genau jetzt kannst du sie einmal in die
phase 1
[Musik]
jetzt fühlt sich nicht schlimmer als da
wo ich das gemacht habe
doch woran sieht man wie viel farbe das
geld sie keine frage das eigentlich
unangenehm so angenehm wie tattoos halt
sind also ich weiß nicht wie sich das
anfühlt es schmerzt schon bis hin
da diese nicht ganz synchron nicht mal
nummer dazwischen oder carina die linie
es gibt da wird das cool
das ist verrückt kammer aus in der
zeitung gestanden hast hast du nicht
einen tick gehabt oder also wurde ja gut
die um meinung habe ich schon mal was
ist wenn ich jetzt drauf liese ich mag
meinen euro und neurologen vor dass ich
einfach dass ich richtig gut geworden
sonne lacht über einen neuen auch die
moschee nein ich merke wenn du ganz
gleich zog da denke ich mir das hat
schon wehgetan ja das stimmt und ich
kann richtig ständig tätowiert haben
jetzt sollen hier weiter also ich fand
es interessant dass immer zu machen
safeconsole ist ein einfach weil die
konzentration so groß da war wirklich
gerne umgebracht aber man erkennt nicht
was das ist ja ein hakenkreuz
mein einziges ziel war ist dass das
tattoo so wird das man erkennt was es
sein so gemein zu hoch aber hat spaß
gemacht
ja also es war toll interessant vor
allem wo ich dann gemerkt habe dass du
diese linien wo ich rein tätowiert hat
dass sie dicker werden und als richtig
fühlen kann
hast du den stuhl eigentlich selber
gemacht dass die sauberen
ja es geht also alle sachen auf diesen
beiden außer das habe ich selber gemacht
ich wollte das auch ausprobieren
im prinzip genauso wie ihr aber ich habe
niemanden gefunden der genug war das
auch sein wenn die [ __ ] die einen blasen
will denkt die sich was hat den schaden
auf die leute zu dir sagen hat nicht nur
bei dir weil die kennen das er aber bei
den jungs und sami khedira her ist der
komplette wird auch hier sind alle
auftrag von stern da gibst du ja
probieren sagt nichts falsches bleiben
so tag nummer zwei wissen mit den ganzen
leuten unterwegs ist auch jemand der gut
eingefügt alte und das ist eine lüge
wir sind jetzt essen sind auf dem weg zu
vögeln die auf der hand landen
das neue video ich bin dumm man ist ja
langweilig wollte so schneiden dass du
sagst ich bin jetzt richtig und im kongo
sonja guten männer mama schau ich bin am
wandern ohne dass du mich zwingen muss
[Musik]
du kannst den zuschauern sagen wie
schlimm es hier ist leute ist es
wirklich schrecklich hier ist
unerträglich einen ordner in dem man
kann ich nur bestätigen mails bestätigen
kann ich da auch nicht tun sonst wäre es
keine bestätigung gibt sie mir da und
sieht einfach nur scheiße aus
ich möchte bitte wieder nach hause mama
sagen sie dazu funktioniert nicht kommt
aber so eine art die hand aus wehr sogar
sebastian kannst du dich bitte da
hinstellen land nämlich wieder tauben
bruder buck sind nur locker 200 meter
die hälfte der nutzer gegessen und die
andere hälfte gewicht bekommen bruder
[Musik]
geil alter was soll die scheiße komplett
verarschen mehr dumme kuh in gold
erzielt
[Musik]
der sohn ist also nicht nur vögel kann
man hier finden sondern auch katzen los
und damit dir du kannst jetzt mit mir
ist jetzt hier unter geschwistern lebt
wir nehmen dich jetzt
was hältst du von katzen ich habe eine
allergie gegen katzen
das ist mir egal schließlich achtung
gefährlichen haben muss das auch
schaffen durch moody's ist so ein
horrorfilm sein maxime was ist das
gefährlichste situation wir müssen uns
auf jeden fall trennen
ich weiß wirklich rein weil das uns was
ich hier was vor der laptop jetzt werde
ich alle uns entgegenkommen den begrüßen
soll das keiner sagt hallo und erst
treffen kleine vögel dann katzen jetzt
chicken nuggets kommt her
seine blüten ich kann mich macht es tut
mir leid was schnell die bank ganz
einfach ganz gut macht man eine vase
kaputte soll vielleicht in weiteren
studien will ja das war zu viel angst
ist zu sehen wenn ich das video gefallen
hat lassen like und ein abo da wir sehen
uns morgen wieder biss dann ja vielen
dank an jahren für das tattoo und tim
und jahren allgemein für die schöne zeit
des vereins